foreign
[Music]
today we're going to discuss all the
things we know so far about the upcoming
Super Mario Brothers movie if you liked
the video be sure to leave us a like And
subscribe to the channel to not miss out
on any future content regarding your
favorite movies without further Ado
let's get started
the upcoming Mario motion picture will
be a computer animated movie made by
Illumination in collaborative efforts
with Nintendo and produced and
distributed by Universal Pictures is the
third showcase movie version of
Nintendo's Mario series of video games
following the 1986 japanese-only
animated film Super Mario Brothers the
great mission to rescue Princess Peach
as well as the 1993 live action film
Super Mario Brothers Nintendo was
reluctant to permit its intellectual
rights for movie versions after the
commercial and critical defeat of the
1993 movie Shigeru Miyamoto became
interested in making another Mario movie
when Nintendo was trying to bring its
classic games to the Virtual Console
business and he met illumination
chairman Chris meladandri via Nintendo's
work with Universal Parks and resorts to
generate Mario themed sites by 2016 the
two were addressing a Mario movie and in
January 2018 Nintendo revealed that it
would be manufactured in collaborative
efforts with illumination and Universal
by 2020 production had officially
started it will be approximately 30
years ever since the official launch of
the live-action tragedy movie with the
same name the gloomy glum and everything
not so fun movie frequently viewed to be
one of the worst computer game movies
ever made ceased even to attract people
of the game franchise to the cinemas
upon its official launch in May 1993.
the film starring Bob Hoskins John
Leguizamo Dennis Hopper and Samantha
Mathis took a significantly wrong turn
from the route to the Mushroom Kingdom
but rather gave viewers what could be
best characterized as a waking nightmare
the upcoming animated movie will be
directed by Aaron Horvath and Michael
jelenik who joined forces on the DC
Comics animated TV show Teen Titans Go
and the 2018 screenplay Teen Titans go
to the movies in addition to including
two high-profile filmmakers
illuminations Chris melodandre and
Nintendo Shigeru Miyamoto will actually
maintain the Super Mario Brothers movies
racecourse Nintendo and illumination
also officially confirmed that the
film's storyline will be authored by
Matthew Fogle who also authored The Lego
Movie 2 the second part and minions the
rise of Gru which completely destroyed
the competitive market when it made its
debut in July 2022
according to findings the movie will
proceed with storytelling from the
original Mario lead character Charles
martinet will show up in cartoon form to
recollect Mario's background story The
Narrative then transitions to the
current time where Mario is well known
while conducting an investigation on
some malicious Kong and Coop behavioral
patterns in the sewer system he
supposedly confronts an elderly and
irritable Donkey Kong and the two
slipped down a pipe and eventually winds
up in the Mushroom Kingdom Bowser and
Princess Peach are then formally
introduced and Bowser abducts Peach
afterwards on this occasion it is said
that a seriously concerned Luigi follows
Mario into the sewer system and plummets
the pipe to the Mushroom Kingdom where
he sets foot in the midst of the forest
and confronts Yoshi in the meantime
Mario has said to scramble into a battle
with Bowser who overpowers him and
tosses him into the woods reconnected
with Luigi and Yoshi the three combat
some quippy Bowser copies who when
conquered convert into an ugly
unspeakable mixture of foes when the
team hits Bowser in his jumps the
ultimate war starts we don't want to
explore the possible plot of the movie
any further in case those rumors and
theories turn out to be 100 true this
possible plot sound realistic to you let
us know in the comments down below
Shigeru Miyamoto the creator of Mario
and a percentage of the film's other
memorable figures appeared on screen to
describe the Super Mario Brothers film
during the September 2021 Nintendo
Direct occasion Miyamoto could not
disclose any specifics regarding the
storyline or how it appears to fit into
the series fiction which goes all the
way back to 1981 but he did confirm the
cast first up is Chris Pratt who will
add to his already crazy schedule by
characterizing Nintendo's emblem Mario
Anya Taylor Joy who performed Princess
Peach in Super Mario Brothers will join
him in the crew others include Jack
Black Charlie Day Seth Rogen Keegan
Michael Key Fred Armisen Kevin Michael
Richardson Sebastian Maniscalco and
Charles Martinez with a voice cast like
this there is a very decent possibility
Nintendo's trademark personality will
get very much the fairy tale ending when
the movie officially launches in Spring
2023 all of those selections seem decent
fits for their positions however nothing
could have primed fans for the
revelation of Chris Pratt as much Mario
this sent reverberations through nerd
society and it felt as though we were
getting punked at the exact same time
moreover melodandre asserted that the
action star wasn't going to perform with
an Italian accent Prada's Mario is still
as entertaining as it was one year ago
but fingers crossed the actor will be
capable of bringing the same appeal to
this renowned plumber that he appears to
have done to Emmett in The Lego film
series
although it is only just now getting
momentum this Super Mario Brothers film
has been in creation for over 10 years
the Wall Street Journal announced in
November 2017 the Nintendo and
illumination entertainment were joining
forces to create an animatronic movie
based on the pioneering series of video
games however unlike the live-action
Super Mario Brothers film which became a
box office disaster upon its official
launch in 1993. Nintendo would preserve
some editorial freedom and have a say in
the development via this collaboration
only one movie was affirmed at the time
ideally many will pursue it if the movie
is a box office hit
when the Super Mario Brothers film
reaches North American movie theaters on
April 7th 2023 the iconic video game
Champion will hitch a ride into the
hearts of filmgoers the video game
modification was initially set to hit
Cinemas in December 2022 but Universal
elimination ultimately chose to postpone
it by approximately four months this
transition as per deadline was
manufactured to achieve maximum family
audience members during the Easter break
that's it for today how are your
feelings about the Super Mario Brothers
movie we can hardly wait for the first
trailer which you will of course see
here on our Channel as soon as it is
released what are your expectations from
Chris Pratt voicing the popular plumber
what do you think about the plot let us
know in the comments down below be sure
to leave us a like if you enjoyed the
video and subscribe for more content on
the biggest upcoming Blockbusters until
next time
foreign
[Music]